I've been teaching at MIT since 2001 and
I've taught all kinds of classes but the
innovation I'm excited to be torn out
today is a new set of linked projects
that I helped our mid-career Executive
students the Sloan fellow MBAs on this
past year so I hung up my shingle and
asked students who had a passion for
linking technology with social impact in
some way to come and talk to me and I
created with them a set of projects
which allowed the students to really dig
into areas that they came to MIT
passionate about but also to link it to
their coursework and their degree
program could you talk a little bit
about some of the specific projects that
students did the project students did
ranged greatly but all had as a theme
using what they were learning here and
tapping into emerging or existing
technology in new ways to find solutions
to problems that face many that's the
social impact aspect of it and it took
with each student some effort to really
map out a good enough and focused enough
question that was doable as an
independent study project and that was
deep enough to allow me to really bring
to bear the educational goals that I had
for the projects so one student Doreen
was really interested in the problem of
creating agricultural products in Africa
using crops and products that are grown
right there in Africa why is Africa
importing a lot of consumer products
when the continent has a lot of
agricultural assets so she was really
interested in understanding what are the
business models what are the constraints
what are the opportunities when it comes
to finding new ways to create locally
sourced products that could actually
serve beauty nutrition or other needs
in her native Zimbabwe or elsewhere in
Africa I'll tell you about another
project
Eloy a student who came to me after deep
experience at the World Bank was really
interested in a challenge that
traditional governmental organizations
really wrestle with how do we tap into
entrepreneurship when we're trying to
serve the public good there seems to be
a challenge in linking the entrepreneur
and the public sector and we know that
there are all kinds of innovations that
kind of play in this sphere from ride
sharing and other had and regulated
industries all the way through to
providing in a better way the services
that governments are already on the hook
for so they're either regulated or they
are substitutes for improvements of
services that governments provide and
sometimes they're also missing services
how do you find that what are the
barriers to this where the opportunities
what are the trends and can we actually
map out where we think this field could
go of mixing entrepreneurship and the
public sector one of my students aleni
came to MIT with completely on fire with
this idea of tapping into analytics and
AI to solve what she saw as a major
challenge when it came to bringing
finance to small holder and small-scale
farmers she's an expert on agricultural
finance and she realized that in her
native Brazil and elsewhere people who
didn't have good credit standing and
good credit records farmers who didn't
have those assets couldn't get loans and
were forever locked out so there's a big
dichotomy between the people of access
to finance and those who don't
could she break down that barrier in
some way could new forms of data and
technology help do that so instead of
relying only on somebody's credit record
could you look at the whether they're
farming choices they
behaviors and physical data and use it
to come up with a better assessment of
the riskiness of a given farmer from a
lender's point of view slightly
technical area but it actually has huge
implications because it could open the
door to all kinds of folks who are
excluded from traditional finance by
providing other methods of sorting out
their riskiness and their
creditworthiness so how did it all work
logistically how did you manage to
create all these different individual
projects so that's the downside of this
approach each project was customized
it's kind of a boutique learning
experience in a sense and one of the
things I've learned about trying to
innovate when it comes to teaching is
you have to be willing to invest a lot
the first few rounds the first few years
you do something and then over time you
learn how to make it a little more
efficient streamlined maybe scalable and
more cost effective but this year was
definitely a labor of love
so students came to me with all kinds of
ideas and I had open office hours I have
a wiki page where students can sign up
to meet with me in 20 minute increments
and I would just set up hours of these
meetings every week and sit and talk to
students about their ideas try to
formulate some reasonable next steps
really push them to think about how
they're using their coursework here and
their presence on campus to craft
something they couldn't do anywhere else
and that spoke to everything else they
had access to while they were here so
that process took a lot of
back-and-forth usually I would meet with
students once a week I opened a shared
folder with each of them and would shoot
materials that I found into the folder
and have them load their drafts work
plans and other work in progress there
and then I also would got into a very
quick habit of sending any interesting
reading news article conference notice
directly to the students so some of them
would be getting 10 emails from me but
that really got us going because they
could see I was thinking about it all
week and they were too I learned I had
to keep a whiteboard up in my office
with each project in each person because
I had a over a dozen running to keep
them straight and try to remember who's
doing what so that when I saw it when I
came into the office I had that person
would be on my mind or that project
would be on my mind
Wow do you see this as something that is
potentially scalable in the future I do
one question I've been thinking about a
lot is how you could also use peers
could we craft project kind of clusters
so could we link the themes but we could
we also have students helping each other
coaching each other a little bit could
we use group meetings as a way to
surface a helpful discussion about
what's working and what isn't I think
that that's the next step so that I
think that we'll get to some scalability
I do think mundane as it sounds I think
it's also important to have good like
forms and people work having people
really articulate in writing briefly
what they want to do and having a
structured kind of update process really
helps keep the momentum and build the
focus how do you measure success in
projects like this it's a great question
because students who are following their
passions really get into it you give
them enough freedom they will have a
good time but part of our challenge as
as their teachers is to help make sure
that we're embedding into their approach
enough rigor that we're looking at the
data and the evidence and that it's been
linked to the content we're teaching
here so a passion project by itself may
or may not be academic so there there's
a bit of tension
they're of us having to remind students
of the need to keep making all of these
connections so I would really view
success as when we're able to get the
students to not only pull out develop
polish a great new idea but also to link
it to what they've been learning here
and test their ideas with a level of
attention to that data even if it's
qualitative that really we can all stand
behind and how did you do that in in
these projects so part of the
requirement is to really make sure that
if a student there's actually quite a
lot of work in trying to unpack the
logic the thinking behind a new idea and
I would spend a lot of time trying to
help figure out where is it we need to
drill down to back up this idea where is
it that we use the literature and the
research where you're going to do desk
research to sort of shore up one leg of
what you're doing and where is it that
you're gonna gather new information
whether it's by observation by
interviews by other methods that you can
bring to bear so you I really want it
was looking for both where's the link to
other people's work to the research in
the literature where's the link to
something new that you've uncovered and
then using methods that you were going
to describe systematically I see the
great thing about this is that it helps
me to learn so part of what I think the
huge value in teaching this way is that
you as the instructor have this like
gift of hearing new ideas that aren't
necessarily embedded into the academic
structure yet so I discovered there
really is a need to build a better
theory and framework around public
entrepreneurship that's that's really
interesting that helps me think about my
own research goals and where I might
build new collaborations here on campus
other faculty and researchers in
speaking of collaborations what was the
role of networking in this experience
for our fellows so students coming here
have varying predilections for
networking and connecting with others
and many of them really benefit from
having a focus to that so very often we
tell students you have this gift of
being here on campus for a while make
the most of it
but if you're just trying to meet people
to fill up your rolodex
it's rather self-serving and it's
awkward and there's no reason to meet
but if you can articulate a really
interesting question this gives students
a reason to contact people so I really
view the two is linked develop a great
problem statement or research question
use that to look at what you have access
to on campus that might include faculty
postdocs research teams that might
include alumni it it includes folks
within the MIT sort of ecosystems you
might head over to an incubator or some
other a venue an event where people are
and then because we get a lot of people
passing through as well as invitations
to meetings conferences and events
globally I would shoot those to my
students so say so-and-so is coming to
campus next week you know see if you can
get on their agenda and that would often
work yeah how are you looking to tweak
this experience the next time you teach
it so I think having the steps in the
process a little bit clearer and having
the motivating question of each step in
a project like this really central so
early stages here's what you should be
thinking about here's the questions you
need to answer middle stages late so if
I have a better framework for the steps
in the work I think that's a that would
be a big benefit
and others to realize not every student
who comes in with their passion project
is necessarily gonna want to or should
turn it into an in-depth study so I've
learned that you can't convert everyone
and that's okay mm-hmm
it's it's it's because we're offering it
this is an offering of a new learning
experience it's very much driven by the
students interest you need to really be
able to allow the students to
self-select
in it's hard to offer something like
this as a requirement so that's another
piece is striking the right balance
between kind of opening the door and
inviting people in this is cracking the
whip and following up on them students
get really busy so one downside of an
unstructured course is that it can fall
by the wayside because they have their
structured requirements and course
meetings for all their other classes and
this begins to feel like something on
the side so how you kind of maintain the
momentum and make sure that enough
investment is going in is really
important so better sort of sourcing and
screening better process and having kind
of regular meetings are all really
important ingredients is there anything
else you'd like to share about
facilitating an experience like this
that we haven't touched on yet I think
one of the challenges that an instructor
has to balance is how far am I willing
to go outside of my domain of expertise
how much do I know about the blockchain
that's not an area of my research so how
far do I want to go down a set of
projects that take that on I need to be
able to figure it out for myself and
then also be very clear with the
students I'm interested in this topic
I'll learn with you but my domain of
expertise relates to these areas we can
apply it to your questions we can apply
systems thinking or organizational
change or business models
to the questions you're articulating but
I am not the technical expert on this
domain so you'll need to work with
someone else on that and different
instructors have different interests and
stepping out of their comfort zone so
that I think that's really important
another big question is how willing are
you as an instructor to have a mishmash
of projects that take on very different
domains or would you like them to be
geographically or thematically linked
hmm
I suspect that I'm gonna evolve a little
more towards clustered projects and I've
seen some of my colleagues use such
clusters of projects over time to build
their own research insights so I think
that's really exciting the idea of
encouraging students to take on projects
that motivate them but that also speak
to an ongoing research program and on
which you can start to build more
knowledge and evidence do you have any
words of advice to your colleagues out
in the world who might want to try
something similar teaching this way is
incredibly rewarding and also really
scary you often be invited into domains
we don't have the expertise and it's
quite hard to predict how a given
session or a conversation will go it's
not like running a case where you know
the story and you know what you're gonna
say at each moment in class or you're at
least got a sense of what that might
look like because very often students
will come in and say I've totally
changed my mind and you have to deal
with that so there's both the kind of
personal journey of learning that's less
predictable and the domaine part that's
less predictable but you as the
instructor get to set some of those
parameters by for instance requiring a
written update before a meeting you can
manage the conversation better and by
specifying the specific the types of
projects that you would really want to
take on
you can also ensure that they're
clustered in
that are relevant to your own expertise
for me one of the challenges I have to
tell you is branding
what do I call this is it something
different than just doing a bunch of
independent studies I think it's a work
in progress so I think the first few
times you try out something like this it
doesn't yet have a fully distinct
identity and then as I hone it I'm gonna
give it a clearer name but I've been
using terms that link to social impact
that link to technology and that also
frame perhaps because it's focusing on
the students I'm teaching but the idea
of thinking strategically thinking as a
leader and really kind of putting
yourselves in the shoes of the of an
entrepreneur or an executive so I want
them to not simply kind of make general
arguments about what should happen but
to think about what they could do as a
leader and entrepreneur and executive so
ya come up with a great name I'm still
working on mine all suggestions are
welcome I put in their terms like new
executive thinking the social impact or
for it so technology for social impact
so we'll see how that plays out check
back later thank you so much sure